if donald trump gets the supreme court
to consider his case it would echo the
2000 vote
when the court effectively settled the
contested election for george w
bush rt's going underground host ashton
returns he spoke with trump's
impeachment lawyer dr
alan dershowitz on the president's
chances of winning his legal case
if he loses the election by losing
pennsylvania there's a
strong argument that his lawyers can
make
that pennsylvania should not count
ballots that came in
late it's a technical argument but it's
the argument that prevailed in bush
versus gore
and there are already three or four
justices who agree with that argument
but it would take
a combination of circumstances during
the election
to bring that case into a posture where
he would win in the court so i think
it's unlikely that he will prevail in
the courts but that's his best shot
what sort of time scale are we talking
about will it be about a month as it was
in 2000 with bush and gore i think we'll
have a result
within weeks not months if pennsylvania
becomes a key
state then i think it will take months
do you think trump always had in mind
the 300 judges that
were appointed under his administration
uh given that uh
he had already been suspecting vote
tampering
well i think he there were a lot of
reasons why he wanted to appoint lots of
judges
uh his base wants conservative judges
but i think part of the reason may very
well have been
as a backstop as a protection in the
event that
he had to take the election to court any
president would uh
think in those terms what what do you
think
the role of lawyers will be on behalf of
trump will you be helping
the case or do you see that it'll be
giuliani and his team who will be
defending the trump presidency it'll be
giuliani and his team i've known rudy
for
i don't know 30 or 40 years uh i've done
my duty
to the president to the united states of
america by defending him against the
unconstitutional impeachment charge
on this issue i'm going to just sit back
and watch i have my own podcast where
i analyze the case and i will be an
observer
and a commentator but not a participant
supporters of trump say
he shouldn't have given that press
conference on the night saying
there is fraud and waited a little bit
do you think that will affect any court
outcome because he was alleging possible
fraud even before the election and of
course on the night
rather than saying this is the state of
play at the moment
we'll wait and see i don't think that
kind of statement affects the courts and
it was done after the polls were closed
so i think it was just him saying what
he believed and i don't think it'll have
any impact
either electorally or judicially
you